email a test on the English Channel for
the contro Honda test on the English
Channel
they need any
congratulations
foreign
thank you
English
foreign
wait
good morning dear colleagues can I ask
you to take your seats
[Music]
good morning
the session adjourned on the 19th of
January is reopened
two announcements the competent
authorities of Slovakia have notified me
of the election of Miss Katarina
vedalova to the European Parliament
replacing Mr Miroslav chisha from with
effects from 30 December 2022 I wish to
welcome our new colleague and recall
that she takes her seat in Parliament
and its bodies in full enjoyment of her
right spending the verification of her
credentials Miss Daniela rondanelli has
left the non-attached members and joined
the snd group as of the 25th of January
2023 the agenda for this special session
is therefore adopted
dear members dear colleagues We Gather
here today for this solemn ceremony to
Mark the International Day of
commemoration in memory of the victims
of the Holocaust in the presence of the
president of the state of Israel
president Herzog welcome to the European
Parliament
before we begin I would like to invite
you to turn your attention to the
screens to watch a short video in
remembrance of all the victims of the
Holocaust
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
rainbow
[Music]
[Applause]
te
[Music]
spatula casa
is
[Music]
president Herzog distinguished guests
dear colleagues
every year around the 27th of January
the world remembers the millions of
innocent men women and children who were
murdered in History's Greatest crime
a crime intended to wipe off a people
from the Earth
a crime
designed to inflict horror on
Generations
a crime that has shaped our modern
European project into an embodiment of
the Timeless promise never again
it was a crime that sold six million
Jewish people murdered for being Jewish
that saw Roma and sinte people targeted
that saw lgbti communities eradicated
and so many others humiliated and killed
because of their ethnicity disability
identity race or beliefs
it is difficult to imagine the horrors
of the Holocaust and the actions that
led up to it
the fear of mothers and fathers the
quiet suffering of so many
the little children forced to hide in
holes in basements and attics
the rabbis who remained dignified as
they were forced to scrub Pavements wild
crowds laughed and mocked
The Impossible Choice faced by so many
everyday in so many member states
the Holocaust did not happen overnight
Auschwitz
did not fall from the sky
as Survivor Marian turski said three
years ago the alarm Bells should have
rung before
Rabbi Jonathan Sachs gave a lecture in
2012 where he said one of the things
that haunted him about the Holocaust was
the horror of the silence where were the
voices
where were the protests he asked
this was done in living memory
in the Age of Enlightenment rationalism
science and arts and culture
this did not happen in a frenzy of hate
it took time it was built up
the dehumanization process started
before the camps
and what was truly horrifying he said is
the almost total absence of horror at
the time
his appeal was for us to resolve that if
the moment comes we will stand up and
speak out
so that no one will have reason to say
when we cried you were not listening
when we suffered you were silent this is
why even if it is hard to describe these
crimes we must keep speaking why we must
never forget
we must speak because ours is the last
generation to receive first-hand
accounts from survivors of the Holocaust
our duty becomes even greater when the
voices of those survivors cannot be
heard any longer it is our
responsibility to remember and pass down
testimonies to Future generations to
educate we must speak because despite
Decades of effort anti-Semitism still
exists hate still finds too many voices
excusing it too many families in Europe
and around the world live with packed
suitcases by their door we cannot allow
anyone to find comfort in ignorant
ignorance let me repeat what I said in
the knesset
to be anti-semitic is to be
anti-european
our first woman president Simon Vale was
herself a survivor
who grew up to change the face of Europe
and her Legacy is present in these halls
and buildings
she understood that neutrality only
helps the oppressor
and the European Parliament will always
take aside the side of respect
the side of human dignity
decides of equality the side of Hope
this Parliament is proud that we have
not been silent not when it comes to
fighting hate and discrimination not
when it comes to anti-Semitism and
religious freedom and we will keep
acting to ensure that our communities
are not marginalized by exclusion hatred
or indifference
we have not been silent when it came to
standing up for our values nor when it
comes to Russia's aggression in Ukraine
and the rhetoric used to try to justify
it
neither have we been silent when it
comes to the regime in Iran who execute
young people standing up for women life
and Liberty
ladies and gentlemen tomorrow marks
78 years since the liberal liberation of
auschwitzburg now
a Liberation from Evil that proved that
despite everything hope and yours even
when all around is hopelessness
the same hope that led to the
Declaration of the establishment of the
state of Israel 75 years ago this year a
nation that has endured flourished and
sustained a democracy Despite All Odds
president Herzog as I said in Israel the
bond between the people of Europe and
the people of Israel has been forged in
the horror of our common history a bond
whose strength lies in its openness
honesty and straightforwardness even
criticism but a bond that has and will
withstand the test of time and yet our
people share more than history and a
promise to remember we also share a
common Destiny and a future that will
endure thank you
thank you
[Applause]
we will now listen to a musical
interlude by yeno listes lament music by
lachiras
[Music]
[Laughter]
thank you
[Music]
foreign thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Laughter]
foreign
[Applause]
I will now give the floor to his
Excellency Mr Isaac Herzog president of
the state of Israel for his address
president Herzog the floor is yours
[Applause]
they left in 1946
thank you
in 1946
my grandfather on namesake the chief
Rabbi of the land of Israel Rabbi Dr
Ezra Isaac Levi Herzog embarked on a
search and rescue mission
looking for his
Jewish Brethren all across the ravaged
continent of Europe
as he looked around him
he saw not only smoldering heaps of
stone and sand but also the silent Cry
of a downtrodden Nation
the lives of Millions
of men women and children had come to an
end and in their stead he saw a
crumbling Stone
in Warsaw
home to over half a million Jews before
the Holocaust
only the Jewish cemetery remained to
attest to the vibrant life that had
flourished before the Advent of the Nazi
regime
in the in the Nordic synagogue Street
was the only Jewish synagogue that
remained in Warsaw
and a few dozen Souls gathered snatched
from the jaws of carnage I.E
bloodstained Torah scroll was handed to
my grandfather by the survivors to be
taken to the land of Israel for Eternal
memory
the former Cantor of the great synagogue
of Warsaw Moshe kuzowitzki
stood to recite a traditional Jewish
prayer for The Departed
o God who art full of compassion only
this time the wording of the prey was
different than usual
it was different because my grandfather
rewrote the prayer
in order to express if there's any way
to express the pain loss
and grief
that came in the wake of the destruction
that had unfolded before his eyes
he rewrote it and appealed to God and
asked him to Grant rest to our brothers
and sisters victims of the horrific
Holocaust
after the Thousand painful deathly blows
that they had suffered on this Earth
I stand before you today
as the president of the state of Israel
the Democratic nation state of the
Jewish people
but my heart and thoughts are with my
brothers and sisters who were killed in
the Holocaust
their only crime was being Jewish and
the humanity inside them
they were beloved beloved and cherished
they dare to hope and dream even in the
midst of devastation
in their memory I will begin my remarks
with this traditional prayer
oh God who art full of compassion who
dwellest on high
Grant perfect rest on the wings of the
divine presence on the Pinnacles of the
Holy and the pure
which shine like the radiance of the
firmament
to the source of the Six Million Jews
victims of the Holocaust who were killed
suffocated burned and martyred
by the German murderers and their
accomplices from other nations
therefore May the compassionate one
shelter them forever in the safety of
his wings and bind their souls in the
Eternal bonds of life God is their
portion
May the resting place be in the Garden
of Eden and may they stand for their
fate at the end of days let us say Amen
before
Madam president of the European
Parliament Roberta metzola
madame
president of the European commission
Ursula Thunder lion
honored members of the European
Parliament
ambassadors members of parliament
representatives of the Jewish World
ladies and gentlemen
on the afternoon of the 23rd of July
the Jews of the Greek island of Rhodes
stood in a long line
as they faced the Western Wall of the
old city
the rest of the City's population was
forbidden to step outside the Nazis were
were not stated by the elimination of
the Glorious Jewish communities of
Thessaloniki and other cities in Greece
home to 98 of the Jews of Greece
and this way from that
holding site over 1600 Jews from roads
were loaded onto three old cargo vessels
led by SS officers for eight days and
nights and uh nightmarish sea voyage
in a monstrous Odyssey the Jews of
Rhodes sailed at Sea the heat was
intense the food was meager seven people
were killed during the voyage and their
bodies were thrown into the sea
another ship was sent to the island of
course
to pick up nearly 100 Jews and another
ship was sent to the island of leros
a small remote island
in order to hunt down the only Jew who
lived there
only one man that was the whole Jewish
community of leros
one
solitary single Jew he was the last one
his name was Daniel rahamim
the Hebrew word for compassion
as in the prayer oh God who are full of
compassion
The Compassion that he never received
this seemingly small horrifying Hunting
Expedition by the Nazi monster for a
single person the last Jew in a
Backwater Place tells the story of the
entire Holocaust the story of the total
Annihilation eradication and
obliteration the story of the monsters
deranged Obsession to totally
exterminate a nation
whose Roots stretched
back in history
it was a they were an Inseparable and
essential part of Europe
the Jewish people
why did you take a single person why did
you go through all this trouble ask
Daniel rahamim he did not know that for
the Nazis his mere existence was a crime
punishable by Death
that in this case being was a crime
the people aboard these ships reached
Athens after an arduous journey and from
there they were loaded onto cattle
wagons
their destination was the Auschwitz
extermination camp
Daniel rahamim the last Jew from leros
finished off this procession
ladies and gentlemen there are some
dates in history that go beyond the
boundaries of time and become Memorial
sites in 1945
the 27th of January
went from being just another date to
becoming a memorial site when in the
afternoon the gates of hell were burst
open
five horrible years later the Auschwitz
birkenau extermination camp the largest
death factory in human history was
liberated by the soldiers of the Red
Army and stopped operating
snow covered the blood drench soil in
buchenwald in Dachau interesting start
Bergen Belson
and in so many many other places
the horrors continued for several months
until they were liberated
my father the sixth president of the
state of Israel Heim Herzog was at the
time an officer in the British army
he was born in Ireland
he had the privilege of landing at
Normandy across the Rhine and take part
in the liberation of the Netherlands
Belgium and the north of Germany
I will never forget
how he described to me the horrors that
unfolded before his eyes as one of the
first liberators of the death camps in
including Bergen Belson
the human skeletons in the Striped
Pajamas the hell on Earth
the stench
the Heart of Darkness
millions of worlds one third of the
Jewish people were wiped out in The
Killing pits in the gas Chambers in the
furnaces
in the death camps
all of this is simply incomprehensible
wrote
etihilism a young woman from Holland
before she was murdered in Auschwitz in
November 1943 the skies are full of
birds the purple Lupine stand up so
regally and peacefully
the sun is shining on my face
and right before our eyes
mass murder is being carried out
in the Nazis despicable Final Solution
they sought to rip at Europe's own flesh
and blood
for just as Humanity would not be what
it is without Europe
in the same way Europe could not be what
it is without the Jews
can anyone imagine Europe without the
theories of Sigmund Freud
without the genius of Albert Einstein or
eminetter
could there be a Europe without the
Echoes of the thoughts of Karl Marx
how can we conceive of European
philosophy without Barracks Spinoza or
Henry bergson
or the spirit of European culture
without Amadeo modilani or Franz Kafka
however
anti-Semitism like an autoimmune disease
made Europe attack part of its own DNA
and I shared Historia going back
Millennia was erased as if it had never
existed
honorable members of the European
Parliament the Holocaust was not born in
a vacuum
we should never forget that the Nazi
death machine would not have managed to
carry out its nightmarish Vision had it
not met
soil fertilized with Jew hatred
which is as old as time itself
the stereotypical depiction of Jews
had struck roots in Europe for centuries
before the rise of the Nazis for
Generations
and Nazi ideology intensified
traditional anti-Semitism and primordial
fears fan the Flames of hatred
even before a single extermination camp
was built in the midst of the masses the
Jew was already human dust a sub-human
it is precisely for this reason
precisely because the Holocaust was
based on much older anti-semitic
foundations that had taken root and
flourished in Europe that this dark
abyss is a terrible profound and
compelling lesson for the whole of
Europe
as we stand here today
in the Beating Heart of the European
Union
we understand very well the mission of
memory that we'll share
we recognize the fact that the memorial
site to which we make pilgrimage we must
remember not only the Holocaust and the
destruction but also the sacred Alliance
of forged alongside this horrific
disaster we need to sanctify the memory
of the victims
and we need to ensure the welfare of the
survivors who are still amongst us we
need to teach and educate
about the lessons of the historic
catastrophe that was the Holocaust and
we need to prevent any repetition of
these ghastly crimes
today we see movements on the extremes
of European and World politics they
proudly raise the ugly Banner of
anti-Semitism which once more threatens
to turn Democratic and civilized
societies into societies that devour
their own people
unfortunately the picture is very deeply
troubling
anti-semitic discourse
investors not only within dark regimes
but within the heartlands of the free
Democratic West Drew hatred still exists
anti-Semitism still exists
Holocaust denial still exists
the latest reports point to new records
of hatred as anti-Semitism continues to
Don new guises and this time it is act
it is active
alive and kicking on Virtual platforms
as well
throughout the internet viral
anti-Semitism is spreading at a record
Pace at the click of a button
and the distance between a viral video
and a physical attack hardly exists at
all
the distance between a Facebook post and
the Smashing of headstones in a cemetery
is shorter than we would like to think
deranged tweets
can kill they can actually kill
anti-semite store inspiration and ideas
from virtual platforms
they are brainwashed and enraged as a
result of unrestrained and unchecked
online discourse
I stand before you
you who in your identities positions and
beliefs
represent Europe's impressive diversity
at the height of this sacred Gathering
and in the heart of the place that has
always championed a partnership in the
war against darkness and Evil
and the joining of hands to uphold our
most basic core moral and human values
and I Call On You elected officials of
Europe
do not stand by
you must read the warning signs detect
the symptoms of the pandemic of
anti-semitism
and fight it at all costs
you must ensure that every Jew wanting
to live a full Jewish life in your
countries may do so safely and without
fear
it is up to you and your countries to
use every tool at your disposal from
education legislation to security and
enforcement to in order to deter and
eradicate hatred racism and
anti-Semitism in every form
you must instill across Europe the
understanding that the Jewish people's
right to a national and Sovereign
self-determination is sacred and
manifested in our Democratic state
the state of Israel
this is why
amongst other things you must move to
fully adopt the international Holocaust
remembrance alliance ihra definition of
anti-semitism
I wish to underscore there's a fine line
between criticism of the state of Israel
and negation of the state of Israel's
existence it is of course acceptable to
criticize the state that I had it is a
find to criticize us and it is fine to
disagree with us our country is open to
criticism like all members of the family
of Nations
and Israeli democracy
Israeli democracy certainly excels in
fears and penetrating internal criticism
however and this is the important and
critical difference
criticism of the state of Israel must
not cross the line into negation of the
very existence of the state of Israel
the nation-state of the Jewish people as
recognized by the institutions of the
International Community
casting doubt on the nation's state of
the Jewish people's right to exist
is not legitimate diplomacy it is
anti-Semitism in the full sense of the
word
and it must be thoroughly uprooted
the rule is simple
criticism of us must pass the basic test
of fairness and integrity and it must
not cross the line into dehumanization
or delegitimization
the state of Israel Rose Like a Phoenix
out of the ashes and the terrible
destruction and realized our historic
right to a state in our ancient Homeland
in a few months we will celebrate the
75th Independence Day of our country
whose immense contribution to humanity
and to Europe in particular in countless
Fields include science agriculture
energy security technology culture
health education and so much more this
is an established fact
we have withstood enormous challenges
over many years we have absorbed waves
of Jewish immigration from over a
hundred countries from all corners of
the earth we have established a
resilient and Democratic Society
comprised of an unparalleled human
Mosaic of Jews and Arabs people of every
religion and faith
we have proven that we can take any
action at any time and in every place to
protect our citizens and the Jewish
people as a whole
we have courageously weathered attacks
by our enemies and no less importantly
we have extended a hand in peace and a
forged unprecedented alliances
including Peace Accords such as the
Abraham Accords which have transformed
and continued to dramatically transform
the Middle East
I pray for the day when we can reach the
same with our Palestinian neighbors as
well
an essential and fundamental part of our
state's growth rests on the close and
Ironclad ties and alliances with
European States and the institutions of
the European Union the state of Israel
and Europe are bound together in an
unbreakable Bond
our shared interest and even more so our
shared values
predicted our present and shape our
future Liberty
equality justice peace
these are the fundamental values
enshrined in the Declaration of
Independence of the state of Israel
which we shall uphold and defend at any
cost and these are also the core values
of the European Union
I stand here today not only
looking at the past but also for the
sake of the uh
future and our for the sake of our
shared Prosperity so that we may
act in true partnership so that we may
overcome further challenges together
if I call on you and your Nations to
move to broaden and deepen and
strengthen our partnership there's so
much that we can and must do together
for our sake for the sake of the future
and for the sake of future Generations
this is a time of trial for all of us if
we believe
that the voice of justice has not been
silenced if we believe in an in another
more compassionate Humanity we must work
together as a single Community
determined and cohesive against the
forces of darkness and hatred that
threaten to destroy us
as president of the state of Israel I
speak first and foremost of the Iranian
regime which not only publicly calls for
the complete annihilation of my country
the state of Israel
but it is also murdering its own
countrymen and women who are demanding
Liberty and human and civil rights
they are also stoking Civil Wars
throughout the Middle East
playing an active and
lethal role in the war in Ukraine
against Ukrainian citizens and
developing weapons of mass destruction
on the way to dramatically threatening
the stability of the entire globe
to finish my friends
I
until ETI Hill assumed the young poet I
quoted the beginning of my speech was
murdered in the gas chambers of
Auschwitz bear canal
a month and a half before her 30th
birthday
she kept writing in her diary
Eddie wrote about the orphaned children
forced to grow up too early about the
love of mankind that had withered and
about how how much she wanted to live
and her beautiful moving words she wrote
The Following
one day we shall
be able to build a new world and against
every new Outreach and fresh horror we
shall put up more love and goodness love
and goodness that was her dying wish
that was her Legacy that is our duty to
pursue all of us together
made Be Your Will master of peace
came to home peace belongs
to set peace in your People Israel and
may peace grow until peace is drawn upon
every person in the world
this is a Jewish prayer
May the memory of the victims of the
Holocaust be eternally etched in our
hearts and may their souls be bound in
the bond of life amen
[Applause]
dear colleagues kindly kindly remain
standing we will now have a minute of
Silence
thank you
closed captioning not available
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
yeah
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
thank you thank you very much let me
remind you dear colleagues that the
inauguration of the permanent Holocaust
Memorial in our house will start at 11
45 in front of the hemicycle just
outside here and the session of the
European Parliament is adjourned and is
closed thank you
foreign
[Applause]